oh hi you know I've always had what you
might call a love-hate relationship with
the resident evil series I hated the
games and I loved making fun of people
who liked them now seriously I can
understand being impressed by the
original resident evil in 1996 on the
PlayStation like you you know was it was
fun you know going through a haunted
mansion filled with gruesome zombies it
was it was new was ahead of its time the
problem with the resident evil series is
that for like five years capcom just
kept churning these games out and
refused to fix everything that was
obviously broken the control scheme was
garbage why do I have to turn in a
circle instead of just walking where I
want to go why can't I move and shoot at
the same time and don't even get me
started on the story and the cinematics
which were just absurd I said I was
sword my name's Steve
I was a prisoner on this island and I'm
guessing you're not from umbrella either
no and yet I kept trying to get into the
resident evil series mostly because I
mean look at these graphics in in 2002
Capcom remade the first game on the
gamecube and it looked amazing so I
tried to play it again and they still
hadn't fixed all the obsolete design
decisions that by this point we're just
making the series unplayable for anyone
who wasn't already in the resident evil
cult now at this point I was pretty much
ready to give up cut my losses never
play a Resident Evil game again but then
came Resident Evil 4 which finally
slaughtered some of the series most
sacred cows yes you still had to turn in
a circle instead of just being able to
walk like a normal person but with the
camera position behind you it made sense
Resident Evil 4 was the best game in the
series because it didn't feel like a
Resident Evil game and resident evil 5
this really isn't directed in dville
game first of all there's finally a
control option that lets you strafe with
the left stick so no more turning in a
circle it's also an online cooperative
game you're not alone with all the
zombies you've been enlist a partner to
help you out and it's a lot of fun
resident evil 5 just reinforces my
belief that there was something
fundamentally wrong with the resident
evil series because every time Capcom
changed something that was considered to
be fundamental to the resident evil
experience the games got better
unfortunately resident evil 5 also kind
of threw the baby out with the bathwater
it's not really scary anymore a lot of
the levels take place in the daytime it
feels more like Rambo than dawn of the
dead and even though it plays more like
Gears of War now the controls are still
clunkier again based on the flawed
premise that they have to preserve the
resident evil feel this is like not
giving your child a polio vaccine so you
can preserve the fact that they might
become crippled someday which now that i
think about it is probably why resident
evil characters can't walk straight look
I don't think that horror and controls
that actually work are mutually
exclusive okay you can have both you can
be scary and still let the player have
control eternal darkness
demmed guys it's been done before
resident evils producer has said the
next game in the series is going to be a
total reboot fantastic take this
opportunity to throw off the shackles of
1996 once and for all bring back the
horror get somebody who can write video
game stories look at God of War look at
Bioshock write a simpler story like that
resident evil 5 is a great game but the
things that keep it from being truly
excellent are the same things that is
drag the series down ever since the
beginning